the african-american studies department
at yale's endeavor series this is like
our colloquium where we learn um and
wander together uh this being the second
on an anthropology of abolition also an
anthropology of liberation um is here
with a tremendous group of scholars who
i could not be more excited to be
learning from the housekeeping is for
those of you um who are not along
amongst the panel i will encourage you
to turn your cameras off the reason i'm
encouraging you to turn your cameras off
is because
we are recording this and we will
eventually be putting this up online is
the ideal and if you do not want to be
online or you do not want to sign the
paperwork cameras off is deeply deeply
preferred um the other bit is if you
would go ahead and put your questions in
the chat keep your mics on mute and amy
will during the q a be able to
facilitate um those questions for you
please go ahead and put them in the chat
populate them in there i have a feeling
we will have lots of questions for all
the tremendous wisdom we are about to
receive um so with that in this spring
of 2022 is my great pleasure to
introduce the the
trend setting trail blazing pinnacle of
uh the apotheosis of anthropological
excellence amy cox to introduce the rest
of this panel thank you all so very very
much and again welcome to african
american studies endeavors
ah phil thank you so much i knew you
were coming hot so
even a few minutes late it's like phil
comes in hot so thank you so much for
starting us off so vibrantly i also want
to thank vanessa epps who's our senior
administrative assistant in african
american studies for all the work that
vanessa did to organize all the details
around this endeavors series
so wonderful to see all of you here and
more people are still arriving or at
least to see you in your zoom squares
but i'm not at all surprised given who
we are in conversation with
this morning into this afternoon
but first i want to start off by
expressing how profoundly
profoundly fortifying even before we
have begun our conversation the
anticipation
of a conversation with you deb savannah
and kristen is
because i not only have deep respect for
your work but i also care deeply about
you
and i do think that maybe like two and a
half years ago i may have been a little
hesitant to express that sentiment in an
academic context to be completely honest
but much has changed in the past two
years and a half and it has become clear
to me at least that operating as if care
and connection are outside of our
intellectual concern
or irrelevant to our scholarship
constitutes a persistent if subtle type
of violence
and i would add care and connection are
essential for how we think about
abolition and move towards it
so this is a conversation that we have
been having already in many ways across
time phases in our careers several
different institutions and our own
shifting relationship to the academy our
research and the discipline of
anthropology
but this is now a conversation
that takes place in and i'm doing this
these times
over the past two and a half years three
years we have heard the phrase in these
times more than ever
the times that people are referring to
could range from the ongoing global
pandemic and the lives taken in its wake
global protest against anti-blackness
and structural racism
threats to an idealized democracy
the disruption of identities constructed
on strict binaries and scales of
comparison
and the realization that former modes of
supposed stability through financial
security
social respectability
and the accumulation of credentials are
no longer viable
i will pause here but the list could go
on as you know
but these are the times we find
ourselves in which also means these are
the times the discipline of anthropology
and the concept and act of abolition
move within and around
the academic iteration of anthropology
is also currently confronting a long let
me be clear a long history of sexual
violence that is just one let me be
clear just one branch
on the deeply rooted tree of power held
by singular gatekeepers who not only
violate bodies and boundaries but
determine who gets hired mentored
awarded and which scholarship is
legitimized as knowledge
so
when i shared the idea for today's
conversation with a close friend of mine
who happens to be a literary scholar
their response was and i quote
you mean to say the abolition of
anthropology not an anthropology of
abolition right
because the abolition of anthropology is
the only way those two words can be
reconciled in the same breath
and my response was who said we should
be seeking reconciliation
i don't know can anthropology serve the
ideals of abolition
and then what about that slash in the
title the slash and the title between
abolition and liberation
are they truly an and or
or have i too readily assumed a direct
link
can we get specific about our terms so
that they inspire action and
accountability and not just the ongoing
loop of our perpetual theorizing
i don't have easy answers i doubt any of
us do but we do have the gift of three
courageous thinkers to wade in these
choppy waters with us
so
this is how we will proceed today i'll
introduce our three speakers and then
each will offer opening remarks starting
with dr shange can i just can i use your
first names do you mind start starting
with savannah
uh moving to kristen and then with
moving to dev
i'll moderate the conversation for about
20 to 25 minutes before opening up to
your questions and comments so that we
can have a full dialogue in this space
so savannah shange who gets a big hand
clap for joining us at 5 30 in the
morning
should i reveal where you are so we
don't feel so sorry for you
so savannah is an assistant professor of
anthropology at uc santa cruz and also
serves as principal faculty in critical
race and ethnic studies
she earned a phd in africana studies and
education from the university of
pennsylvania
matt is at a masters in education
masters from tufts university and a bfa
in experimental theater from tisch
school of the arts at nyu
her first brilliant book progressive
dystopia abolition anti-blackness and
schooling in san francisco published by
duke in 2019
isn't it that is an ethnography of the
afterlife of slavery as lived in the bay
area and also in savannah i hope you uh
i hope you've added this to your file
it's also the winner of the prestigious
baits and book prize that's awarded
through the society for cultural
anthropology
savannah we're so happy to have you here
in your virtual hand clap
kristen a smith is associate professor
of anthropology and african and african
diaspora studies and director of the
center for women's and gender studies at
the university of texas at austin
her work focuses on the immediate and
long-term impact of policing on black
communities black communities in the
americas
particularly on black women
she is the author of over 20
peer-reviewed articles and essays
multiple public commentaries and a
brilliant book afro paradise blackness
violence and performance in brazil
published in 2016
which won an honorable mention for the
errol hill award in 2017.
kristen is also currently completing
three books
is that true kristen no
kristen is that in the middle of three
brilliant book projects which i hope
you'll talk about as we get into our
conversation
debbie thomas deborah a thomas is the r
gene brownlee professor of anthropology
and the director of the center
for experimental ethnography at the
university of pennsylvania
she's the author of political life in
the wake of the plantation
exceptional violence and modern
blackness
thomas co-directed the documentary films
that friday and four days in may
and she is the co-curator of a
multimedia installation titled bearing
witness
four days in west kingston
prior to her life in the academy she was
a beautiful she still is not prior to
you still a dancer but she was a
professional dancer with the new
york-based urban
bush women can we give our um a virtual
hand clap to our esteemed panelists
today
so i'm going to open up with you all
opening up
in your opening remarks and i i want you
to open up in whatever way feels right
to you but
if this is a helpful prompt i thought we
might kind of
interrogate some of the assumptions that
i might be making in the terms that i'm
using
so abolition
is a word that many of us
use now i would say in the past maybe
five years it's become more mainstreamed
associated with policing in the carceral
state more specifically but then now it
has this sort of traffic and people are
sort of attaching it and the way that we
do in the academy and there's this
assumption that we're all using it or
understand how we're using it
and i'm wondering um how you enter this
conversation
and your relationship to the concept of
abolition but then i thought am i also
making an assumption about anthropology
right do you in this moment consider
yourself an anthropologist what is your
relationship to the field
um because your work is
housed in an anthropology department and
read by anthropologists or not
how do you assess your relationship to
the discipline of anthropology
and this could be within and outside of
the academy and then how do we reconcile
or not you know referring to that
question from my friend
the concept of abolition and and what we
what we understand to be the practice of
anthropology
or you can just ignore that and just
whatever you want to say to open up is
fine
but we'll start with savannah savannah
i'm going to turn it over to you
uh thank you so much for that really
beautiful introduction amy um and it's
so wonderful to be here with so many
folks who have um literally uh shaped my
path to this moment so it's wonderful to
be here with you kristen deb too
um so
yes i feel like this past
year
and a half has really i think
highlighted for me the need to be clear
about what it is that
it means when we say abolition because i
feel like 10 years ago it i feel like
people who said it i was on the same
page with them right um and now it's
we're in a different moment um and
actually just recently i finished um
working on a piece trying to work
through this very
concern so i think i'll share maybe a
couple pages of it and then talk about
how it brings me back um to this moment
and so it starts do you remember
uh maybe some folks here june and july
2020 when in addition to our communities
you know uh
raised rising up in the streets our
colleagues who were not in the streets
were rising up in our emails to ask us
to appear every six minutes you remember
that right and so what started as a
series of you know we had some really
generative conversations but then on
when you're on the third talk in the
sixth week right um you start being kind
of a black thought vending machine right
it's a pez dispenser for bites of
abolition and i realized i'm just gonna
say i put myself in that position
by putting abolition in the subtitle of
my book not knowing this is where i was
going to be in this moment and so i
really i've been thinking about what it
means to use
um the kind of boolean logics that come
out of search engines like google right
in the ways we even literally title our
work right because then the same engines
of surveillance and kind of digital
capture then serve to
lubricate certain kinds of pathways
um to finding um
certain kinds of works as an entryway
something like abolition when there's
other places um namely the streets that
you live on and the places that we work
right that are better entrance points at
least i think more earnest ones
and so i was asked in one of these
sessions
how do you maintain faith in
anthropology while doing abolitionist
work
and this was a really earnest question
from a fantastic and you know super
engaged uh graduate student
and
i realized that i had
the fact that this was the question
really let me know how off path i was
because embedded in the logic of a
question like this and this was a good
faith question this was not you know
this is someone really trying to do the
best work they can imagine
there's a twin assumption that one
anthropology and abolition are
reconcilable
and that two my spiritual investments
include academic discipline right that's
wrong on both counts but it's really on
me for having set that up
and so
i think that
as someone who for better or worse has
like hung my hat on abolitionist
anthropology as a phrase i think i set
but set up both the audience in these
kind of spaces and myself for the okie
doke because monographs are meant to be
consumable right they're bitable they're
citable and abolition is supposed to be
ignitable right these aren't the same
kind of function and i think it's
important to remember that abolition is
not a metaphor right and that our notion
of abolition
um it's essential that it doesn't get
defanged and deracinated within these
kind of self-evident boundaries of a
discipline or the academy and so
to maintain faith in abolitionist work
in anthropology while doing abolitionist
work
implies a temporality in which like amy
said the discipline is ongoing and
abiding right while abolition would be a
tactical modifier of labor in the
meantime
the desire to deserve to conserve the
discipline in the face of impossible
demands hearkens to ryan what ryan
johnson
that same year named the anthropological
fix right whether it's technological
statist velosian
and ryan reminds us that rather than
looking to the discipline to bolster our
faith quote the decisive action required
to resolve in crisis and anthropology on
the contrary will not be confined to the
halls of convention centers or
university departments and of course not
to like a zoom webinar right because
abolition is not a fix
it's the reverse and unfixing in the
sense of disrupting both the locus and
the function of captivity
given the distance between our
disciplines liberal center of gravity
and the demands of abolition it becomes
clear that the question from this
graduate student had it all backwards
right instead i'm wondering the reverse
how do we maintain faith and abolition
while doing anthropological work right
and so i couldn't think of this
at the moment this is kind of
i was thinking about this in response to
um this really kind of generative
question
and for me the answer is clear
every empire falls in this little
settler dumpster fire that we find
ourselves in is no different right
the planet that we fret so much about
will be absolutely fine right the earth
will heal itself and regenerate life
time and time again over the next
billion years the question is about
whether humans will be around to bear
witness
and so any student of history knows the
structure of the united states like any
nation state is also going to change and
morph in one way or another in the next
few hundred years
but most likely those transformations
will fortify the fatal forces of white
supremacy and patriarchy right
um the question is how we intend to both
shape and survive those transformations
right so in 2021 23
will we see the north american corporate
military structure grow even more
powerful in the ruins of neoliberalism
or will we see autonomous communities
accountable to indigenous lands to words
hold large swaths of land will it be of
both right
and so i think
um
i think the last piece i'll share here
is about where ethnographic practice
practice and anthropological ways of
knowing fit in here
and i think
that amidst all of the kind of morass
that the person you were talking about
amy was saying this has to go right
amidst everything that has to go into
the bin let's think of it as a compost
pile that the anthropology has to go
into right which means it's gonna have
to decompose and something else could
potentially be fed from that um and
particularly this part of the
disciplinary toolkit that are really
useful for world making listening deeply
bearing witness
challenging the inevitability of the
state right building deep transnational
and cross-diasporic relations
in particular as kind of surveillance
and policing and imprisonment become
globalized as techniques of oppression
anthropology can help us disrupt u.s
centrism while cultivating thicker
solidarities that function as political
kind of pathways
and so for me
abolition's about attending to the break
stretching open the cracks in
captivity's infrastructure an
ethnographic practice is a technique
that can help us attend to life as it is
in this moment one that has the
potential to attune us to world making
as it's happening everywhere right
and so
um
amy do i have another minute
please please okay
so um so was anybody at one of the first
critical resistance conferences that's
here feel free to say in the chat do
y'all remember the one there was one at
maybe
uh i was at the wine at columbia but
there's one before that maybe at
riverside and so at these initial um cr
conferences in like
97 and 99 correct me on the the years
um when folks said abolition it was
understood as a very direct reference to
the destruction of the prison industrial
complex right policing wasn't even that
central to the table at that moment i
was really specific about the prison
industrial complex what some people
would now kind of call mass
incarceration but that's not the call
the call is to end all incarceration
right not justify certain people's
captivity um
in order to free others and of course
the theory of prison abolition was not
born at that conference or any
conference and kind of the history of
anti-cultural thought goes back you know
depending on how you want to map it from
you know the boys from
uh
there's lots of ways to think about it
joy james has a great kind of
historiography of that
but it wasn't until the 2020 uprisings
that the abolitionist proposition
pierced to mainstream us consciousness
with the koji demand right defund the
police and there was so much hostility
and patronizing happening in response to
that that folks literally like mariam
cobb had to literally write a op-ed that
said yes we mean literally abolish the
police
and so in the meantime there's just been
this rebranding and kind of bad faith
efforts to co-opt abolition as anything
but right and have plenty of examples of
that that i won't share
um but for me what i've been thinking
about is what are the different modes of
abolition so even among those who are in
the in the wheelhouse of okay ending
captivity and all of the things that
could cause it there's still a lot of
kind of generative diversity within that
frame and so i've been thinking about
abolition um as kind of five years of a
moving stick shift vehicle stop shout
out to everybody who can drive manual um
using chela sandoval's on theory of
differential consciousness that works
through a gear and so those gears would
be
we might think of as abolition as
rupture right which is changing the
conditions of captivity right rupturing
the common sense that produces captivity
so someone like mariam cabba and the
insight collective right those are folks
who are moving in this world also
thinking about anthropologists that
engage that i actually think of your
work kristin um as really moving in that
mode of abolition in the sense that yes
you attend to anti-black state violence
in brazil in the us but also to the
sequelae the trail behind that
spectacular event of violence and the
lives of mothers partners and children
of the slain right and so by tracing
those afterlives of violence that mirror
this kind of threat of neglect and harm
you make sure that we interrupt yes the
spectacular event but also the threads
that come before and after it right
um you might think that there's another
mode of abolition that's abolition as
revolution right direct confrontation
with the state a kind of tradition of
abolition that draws its power directly
from ongoing revolutionary struggle led
by incarcerated people and political
prisoners so folks like joel costa
vargas or some britain right engage in
this tradition even within anthropology
um and they're not doing that work as
anthropology they're doing that work as
anthropologists
right and so and trying to figure out
how that happens you also might um look
at folks who use abolitionist healing
right really doing that work of
accountability and transformation and in
doing the work of creating practical
safety in our communities and
transforming the impact of interpersonal
harm and so someone like brendan times
who works on survivor organizing i think
really kind of lifts up that tradition
of abolition in our discipline um out
the last two were thinking about
abolition as geography right building
spaces of self-reliance and so i'm
looking to someone like ashante reese
and her work around self-reliance to
help us sketch out what might that
practice look like
um in the discipline
and finally abolition as culture right
as the practice of finding one another
and building um kind of spaces between
people because abolition is something
that only lives in the space between
people and so here i'm thinking about
deb your work um not just kind of the
end product of the films um you know the
of the
film
uh and the so thinking about bad friday
thinking about bear witness but also
thinking about the long-form process to
produce those as operating in that um
kind of register also like the podcasts
or his daughters the site black women
collective right this work of producing
um
abolition between us and then for me
i'll just take it home
with um
the
folks that i learned most about
abolition from is the black organizing
project which is an organization that
i'm a member of
i'm an anthropologist who is a member of
the organization i'm not an
anthropologist of the organization right
i push in chairs you know i tuck in you
know pushing chairs i make phone calls
i'm on the phone tree um this image that
you see here
is from um a retreat that some of the
organizers put together
this is the crew of folks who have been
um
holding the george floyd resolution for
the elimination of school police in
oakland which successfully passed in
june 2020 the
oakland school police department has
been abolished the guns have been melted
down the car is decommissioned they are
off the payroll right and in the past
year and a half it's been this group of
people that have been helping to create
new um job descriptions for the security
staff they've been creating new safety
trees for different kinds of incidents
at the elementary middle school and high
school level right really doing this
kind of dreary week-to-week week work of
producing abolition in real life um and
so i brought them here as my own kind of
guide to this work
thank you so much savannah so so much to
think with
i'm you know i'm just thinking about the
five i don't know if you would call them
tenants or or
entry points or
um interventions in the way that you
think of abolition but each one of them
gives us gives us so much to think about
and um what i love about that is it
doesn't
begin an end with an ultimate rupture is
not the beginning of it right rupture is
is one node
and so that there's a way that we can
see the work that we're doing the steps
towards
a bigger rupture if we want to call the
rupture of the revolution there's steps
towards that and there's ways that we
can
um see that in our work and the daily
work that happens whether it's inside
the academy or outside of it so that we
don't have to constantly
be operating in these false binaries of
activist non-activists in in sort of
sort of old school ways that don't speak
to the ways that we can
um
be attuned to the possibility for
transformation and what might seem like
the smallest acts while still not
relying on those small acts to do all of
the work
right but there's a progression in the
way that we understand what abolition
means or what it could mean so thank you
so much for that
um kristen
i'm going to turn it over to you
thank you so much um
before i get started i just want to make
sure i thank everybody so i definitely
want to thank you amy for pulling this
all together
um it's just really it's beautiful to be
in in conversation and i know that we're
not in person but there's something
comforting about seeing
all of these wonderful and amazing faces
that have inspired my work i i'm gonna
echo um savannah's words uh savannah's
work your work amy deb's work have
really inspired the work that i do as
well and so i just feel like i'm in
community right now and i just want to
say thank you um and i also want to say
thank you to vanessa epps as well for
helping us get all organized um prior to
this moment and thank you for the to the
department of african
of african-american studies um and the
yale endeavors series for allowing us to
be in conversation
so i want to start just really really
briefly because i'm not sure
um
how much people know who i am or what my
work is and so i just want to start by
saying um
i'm going to talk about
uh
the anthropology of liberation and
abolition right and i definitely want to
get back to some of the things that
savannah said because savannah your
interventions about those five points i
really appreciate them and they got me
thinking about something so i can't wait
to talk to you about them
um
but my work has focused on
uh thinking about the terrorizing impact
of policing on black people particularly
in brazil
but across the americas
for the past 20 years and so
when savannah mentioned the fact that
you know in
summer of 2020 when all of a sudden
abolition becomes this mainstream word
for many of us who have been doing this
kind of work around
anti-black policing for quite some time
that was a vertigo moment um it felt
really
interesting because it meant that the
hegemony was shifting
it meant that the terms that we have
been
using for quite some time have been
pulled out from under us
and so i want to just kind of underscore
that because i think that that was part
of the thread that savannah was getting
to but i think that one of the
provocations that's in this panel is
what do we do with the terms that
comfort us what do we do
um with the politics that we have become
familiar with and where is it leading us
and where do we go with that right
um and so you know quickly my work has
been on the gender dimensions of
anti-black policing and particularly the
unique frequency of black women's
experiences with policing
and what this frequency says about space
about time about gender and anti-black
violence
for me my work and this is going to
sound
different to those of my colleagues who
are
bona fide archaeologists but i really
think of my work as archaeological
right in that it entails excavating the
cemeteries of black life
across the americas
through time and space in order to map
mark and catalog
the artifacts of black life in the wake
of anti-blackness and i used the phrase
in the wake to follow christina sharp's
brilliant theorizations of the wig right
so for me this archaeological work of
tending to the dead and the living
is what anthropologist faye harrison has
called decolonizing anthropology or what
anthropologist kishikan perry has called
an anthropology for liberation
what is that
well in to paraphrase their
understandings of it it's an
anthropological practice that focuses on
the possibility of undoing the cl the
collect excuse me the coloniality of
anthropology through the distortion and
i use that word very specifically
through the distortion of his normative
practice in the service of those that
has historically sought to catalog in
order to be colonized
right
or to follow zoranil hersen hurston
seeking to upturn anthropology's legacy
as the deep practice of white
supremacy's need to know
and so
part of what i see embedded
in
the title of this conversation today is
in actuality a question right um can we
have an anthropology for liberation can
we have an anthropology for abolition
and what are the internal contradictions
that are inherent therein right
so for me
intending to the dead and the living and
and i want to underscore that my work
intending to the living has necessarily
been in community with the debt because
most of the times when i am doing my
ethnographic and anthropological work
i'm working with those who have been
left behind
um after their loved ones have been
killed by the police right which is a
very
grief-based
um
and tender practice
i'll just say it that way
and so one of the things that i
am constantly attentive to and this is
something that i also find inspiration
in in deb's work right particularly
around witnessing um and thinking about
how do we have these conversations
in
the aftermath of violence but how do we
excavate
our stories without violating yet again
our graves
after all
grave robbing is a traditional
fundamental element of the
anthropological slash archaeological
process of excavation
in conducting my research i constantly
grapple with this fraught tension
rigorous qualitative research at least
within the bounds of traditional
anthropology seems to require that we as
ethnographers journey into the
communities of the dead to peel back the
layers of people's lives and sentiments
in order to discover the truths of the
past and the present
yet there is something deeply unsettling
to me about this process that pushes us
to rethink the meaning of liberation
what does black liberation look like and
what does it it entail
so
as somebody who spent my entire career
doing work and collaboration with black
movements in brazil
i have learned a lot from
them and from those movements and so i
want to
i want to situate what i'm about to
present as learning from
as opposed to studying on because i
think that that's also one of the themes
that comes through in this conversation
what does it mean for us to engage in
collaborative processes
that are not based on extraction
or somehow based on the continued
processes or continued um
the continued practice
of
genocide for lack of a better word
but instead
seek to learn from and be in community
with
folk in order to find solutions to
our
common experiences
as
people with targets on our backs i'll
put it that way
and so one of the things that i've
learned
is that
if we are to possibly have an
anthropology for liberation whatever
that looks like and i love the questions
that you put to the front um amy because
i'm not sure i'm not convinced of
anthropology i'm also not convinced that
anthropology and liberation can be in
conversation with one another that is
definitely not something that i want to
reify what i do want to do is to say if
that is a possibility if there is
something there what might it look like
right
um and for me
to center black life and black freedom
must necessarily upturn imperialism
upturned heterosexism upturned misogyny
in addition to anti-blackness and i put
those things alongside that because i
think
despite our efforts
we still
engage in the incessant practice
of
linearity
when it comes to understanding
oppression
meaning when we're talking about
anti-blackness we tend to think about it
as separate from gender as separate from
imperialist imperialism as separate from
various heterosexism and things like
that and i think that that is still a
frontier as familiar as that may sound
right
and so
in thinking about that
i have started to think about the
question or the practice the historical
practice of quilombo right or
aquilombasse right which is the practice
of mathematics in brazil
and savannah when you made your comments
about abolition um and abolition as
territory making and
and and community building etc i
couldn't help but think about the
practice of colombo in conversation with
that
because despite the fact that the the
word abolition does not come up in the
conversations in brazil around quilombo
right
we can think about these things in
conversation right in diaspora
conversation um
and specifically thinking about the
practice of colombo to follow beatrice
nacimento
which is this idea not only of building
spaces of refuge but of building war in
campus
and the reason why i want to bring out
the idea of war encampments is because i
think that
one of the things that may allow us to
think about an anthropology for
liberation is to think about it as of
offensive right as an offensive tactic
not as a defensive tactic
and embedded within the notion of
quilombo is an inherent understanding
of the ecologies of violence that we are
up against
it is an inherent understanding that we
must build spaces of refuge we must
build spaces uh that will proliferate
black life and reproduce black life but
entailed in that is defending ourselves
in some way shape or form right
whether that means taking the high
ground and establishing ourselves in the
mountains or that means setting up
autonomous economies or that mean
somehow figuring out a way to fight back
against our oppressors and so
i want to put that on the table because
i think that in order for us to think
about
the possibilities of anthropology and
liberation there must be some sort of
break
going back to something that also
savannah said there must be some sort of
break with anthropology as we know
it and that break
has got to be
has got to be defined clearly
and so if we know anything about
martinage and we know anything about
pilombo the practice of quilombo
in many ways
these are territories that are created
in autonomous spaces that are created by
people who escaped slavery right
um
enslaved africans who fled the
institution of slavery to create
autonomous societies and then fortify
themselves against the onslaught of
violence that was in opposition to black
freedom
what we know is that colombos are never
outside of the colonial space
columbos are never located
in an area that is
beyond the zone of oppression
and so i think for me
that's a helpful place for us to think
about what an anthropology of liberation
might look like because to think that we
are going to get out of the zone of the
zone of the colonial zone of oppression
of anthropology by practicing
anthropology is not realistic but what
does it mean to set up fortified
enclaves of resistance
within a colonial space of war
that will fortify us and lead to the
possibility of our liberation
and so to me
this notion of kilombase
right is one that we might be able to
use
if we are to embrace the possibility of
putting these three terms into
conversation with one another and i'll
end it there thank you
ah thank you so much kristen there's so
much i want to move to death but i just
want to name really quickly there's so
much in what you said but i kept coming
back to something you said early on
about the terms that comfort us and then
i started to think about the way that
terminology and concepts without action
become sort of inebriate us right the
seduction and me and inebriation of
these terms that don't have an action
tied to it but then i was also thinking
about the ways that language is a trap
and can fix
and in some ways not
totally capture what is happening on the
ground so i'm just going to briefly and
some of you have heard this the story
about how i came to anthropology as an
undergrad i was taking a course that i
did not know was an anthropology course
so it was an upper level anthropology
course and we were reading these
beautiful ethnographies
and to me what i recognized and what was
called anthropology but i didn't know it
was called that yet until like sort of
the middle of the semester i realized
what we were up to
it was very much to me a black feminist
practice because the way that we were
talking about these ethnographies and
the practice of
field work was very much about how you
come into a community how you learn how
to be a community how you immerse and
humble yourself
what it means to take people's
experiences seriously to listen to
stories
and to be be a witness more than a
documentarian and this is the way that i
without the name of anthropology there
was a way so if we think about what is
there what is the there there
what could be retrieved i'm wondering if
the terminology keeps us from seeing
what can be retrieved the labeling
of the thing
keeps us from seeing what is possible to
in your terminology kristin excavate
from practices that we're already doing
without having to fix it to a name
so i just wanted to to speak to to speak
to some of that there's so much more in
what you said but i'll just leave it
there because i want to pass it on to
today
well thank you very much um
amy and i echo all of the thank yous
that kristen and savannah have already
put forward thank you for gathering us
thank you vanessa for organizing us um
and you know i love being in dialogue
with you all and uh have missed the sort
of in-person
um
moments of
huddle and
hugs and
laughter
and really good food
and
conspiring
together and i think that is something
that um you know we've really lost over
the last two years and i think that's
also that
a big sense of um
strength you know for many of us going
back to our own institutions are these
moments when we get to
um
draw uh draw energy from that care that
we experience with each other so we do
it online it's not quite the same but it
is um
it is lovely to see your faces
um amy
where you
sort of just intervened i think is where
i might start
um
which has to do with the question of
anthropology and the extent to which we
situate ourselves within a field called
anthropology and you know you and i have
had this conversation before and i'm
sure it's true of
many of us here in this space and beyond
um but i think like like many folk i
sort of fell
into anthropology
i did not apply to phd programs in
anthropology
i had been dancing as amy said with
urban bush women and
even
before that had always been working
through theater or other kind of
performative practices
as a way to
enter community as a way to
think together about you know becoming
conscious together of the problems or
issues within community that we wanted
to confront
and then finding ways through creative
practices through the arts through
just
embodied pedagogy i suppose
to attend to some of those issues and
that was my background as a performer
and that's what sort of drew me into the
academy but um
you know not directly into anthropology
and one of i had applied to a latin
american and caribbean studies program
and that's where i started and one of my
first classes was an anthropology class
and i just
you know remember
recognizing again like you any in the
method
of what we were reading that that was
something that i felt like i was already
doing and and that i didn't realize that
there was a name for
you know and then when i took and that
class was called transnational processes
so you can imagine you know with the
person who would become my advisor
connie said you can imagine it was a
seminar it was a progressive take on
globalization and historicizing the
inequalities um that were becoming
exacerbated in you know sort of late 80s
through the 90s
um and when i then sort of did the
backtracking to do the history of
anthropology and the theory of
anthropology is when i understood what i
was getting myself into
you know and when
i think again for many of us
you
consciously suspend disbelief in order
to get to the thing that you think you
know you're already doing you know
um so
you know yes i'm an anthropologist i i i
love it for the things that you're
talking about for
the method of
learning for the method of being in
community for
um
a mode of
gathering that can enact something in
the world that needs to happen
um but ultimately i guess the way i
consider myself is as a
um
you know someone who assembles archives
you know archives in my case of violence
and of state violence in particular
and of struggles against state violence
and visions of a different world in the
face of state violence but these are
archives that could be
stories they could be performative they
could be sonic they could be
visual and you know the archive itself
is not the end right the archive is then
a tool
um in order to create something else you
know and so i think that's sort of the
basis of
my um the the scholarly work that i do
that ends up in articles and in books
but also the scholarly work that i do
that ends up in
community festivals or films or
performances or
you know other kinds of institution
building and not everything is for
everybody
you know not
not every iteration of an idea is for
all
audiences and so to me it's so important
to think about
audience when thinking about the work
that we're doing you know what do i want
this to do in the world and therefore
who is it for and what form must it take
in order to do
what it's supposed to do for the people
it is for you know
um
so that takes you know that takes on
many different kinds of things and i
guess
what you know it could it could have
been anthropology it could have been
many other things and you know i didn't
go into this to become a professor that
happened at the very last minute
um but you know there could have been
many other professional paths
as well i do feel lucky to be in a space
where
um i have the time
although it never feels like i have time
but you know in theory i have the time
and absolutely have the resources to
distribute you know in other ways and i
guess i see that also as
um part of
a mission you know which is to
uh use the resources of this uh very
wealthy
very large very decentralized
in many ways amazing university toward
the furthering of um
community projects within philadelphia
and beyond
so again that looks like many things it
looks like
a kumina festival that a friend and i
organize every year in jamaica or it
looks like the conversation that we're
hoping to host during the cumina
festival about land dispossession you
know in
you know the particular community but
also tying that to what's going on
nationally and transnationally
um or you know it looks like this
article that i'm really late on about
sovereignty um that i'm trying to put
together for a volume or
um it's a new film that we're working on
that uh really sort of dissects the 70s
in jamaica by looking at the ethiopian
zion coptic church and the kind of
bizarre intervention they made into
you know socialist
politics and
rastafari
race relations i guess i could put it
that way
um
and i think you know though i am
situated in an anthropology department
and have actually been editor of an
anthropology journal i am often not
considered an anthropologist
um or you know i i have
i have heard or overheard i guess people
looking at my book my most recent book
or other work and saying oh it's great
but is it anthropology
you know so i think that um
you know and i'm getting to the
abolition question in a minute but um i
think that
you know while those of us who are
um
intentionally attempting to transform
the disciplinary space that we're in
um are
sort of working through the language of
abolition or of decolonizing
or um
liberation some of the other words that
have been used today
i think it's also important not to be
too attached to the label you know i
think we would be
fighting those battles
anywhere and in any of the spaces that
we
occupy
um so you know some of the work that i
think is super important or that i spend
a lot of my time on right now
is also creating spaces within this
institution
um that are really about undoing
ultimately are about undoing the
institution um and
our center is a space like that the
center for experimental ethnography and
we were very privileged to host amy as
one of our first
fellows
but that center is
organized to support faculty and
students who have a creative practice as
the basis of their research process
and we have had filmmakers we have
dancers and choreographers we've had
visual artists textile artists we've had
sound
artists um
creative writers this semester we had
amitabh ghosh and we staged a musical
version of a parable that he recently
wrote
um
and you know
the point is to understand artists as
intellectuals and creative work as
intellectual work and to therefore
transform the modes of knowledge
production right so in a way it's trying
to bring the university to what i
understood as knowledge production
before entering
um
the university
so
in that way it is about decolonizing
and um in that respect i also would say
that all of these words that we use
i would
um
i tend to use them in the gerund form
you know even to think if we agree that
sovereignty is a process and a practice
and that liberation is a process and a
practice
then you know obviously decolonizing and
abolishing are also processes and
practices and they're not events you
know they're not something that happens
and we can say oh we're done you know
we've we've solved
that problem
it's an ongoing modality
of
life and i think um
that oh thank you
for putting that in the chat
um
that uh guides
me um you know in sort of
everything um everything i do you know
so like in considering you know am i
gonna give this talk or am i gonna work
on this project or are we gonna
co-sponsor this event or you know
whatever it is it's who is it serving
who is the audience how does it move
through a process and practice of
decolonizing abolishing liberating
um and you know how does it create joy
in our worlds and in our lives
thank you so much i um
as you were speaking deb was thinking
about how much of the work of abolition
is about remembering
what you know what i knew before i came
to this what i was already doing what i
had been doing in that through sort of
the training and the disciplining of our
minds and our bodies and
you know
a context post all of that
that our work that maybe the first step
in abolition is a remembering a deep
honoring of what we we already know and
we hold in our bodies and in our spirits
um and i just want to say you know for
for everybody listening i know you're
listening intently put there's some
questions in the chat that i want to get
to and what i've tried to do um
as you have been giving your opening
remarks is just kind of pepper in some
things that i want to expand on as in
between your remarks
and really because what you're saying is
so rich and so sort of layered you kind
of hit on the other prompts that i
wanted to ask so i want to make space
for us to be in genuine conversation
because people always say that like it's
just a conversation and then it's not so
you know and i think kristen said this
was the first one to say i want to ask
you more about this
to savannah so i want to open up space
before we move to
the questions in the in the chat for you
all to talk to
one another if there's questions that
you have
of one another about your work about
something that you said today i just
want to allow that space for us to
practice
practice cops see that to practice
conversation
for us to be
to be in conversation
um
so i'll just open it up i don't know if
you if there was something that you
wanted to start with kristen i was gonna
say i'm i'm like jumping into the line
yeah you have a couple of questions
exactly savannah i'm like jumping in um
i
so
one i have two questions and and one is
for savannah and one is for deb um
i would really
appreciate because part of what is
really inspiring to me about your work
savannah is
just how much practice
or praxis
um is the center of your work on
abolition right and so everything that
you do is in conversation with community
and and in thinking about those five
understandings of abolition i just
wanted to hear you talk a little bit
more um about how we create
those possibilities in community and
what does that look like right
um and for deb
you know i
i am always inspired by your research
and all the amazing kind of community
work that you do but i am also inspired
by the ways that you engage in
institution building and disruption
which is one of the things that you
mentioned and
and one of the things that i think has
been um
a key aspect of that is your ability to
bridge community with the university
and so i wanted to hear you talk a
little bit more about how we do that
work because i think that that is part
of the process
of decolonizing or liberating or
abolishing whatever gerund we want to
use
um i think at the heart of this this
conversation
is that process of breaking down the
university walls
and i think that cce is a good example
of see me c-e-e is a good example of
that and i wanted to hear you talk a
little bit more about that
i love these questions look before
i know it's not my turn to ask a
question but i'm just going to say it
anyway when you said the hegemony is
shifting
that is so i mean i don't know if my
trekkies are out there but it's like the
borg is adapting it's like just thinking
about the ways in which um oh child you
see they got me they got me i just said
i just said the ways in which they got
me
thinking about how
um
malleable and how adaptive how like
fundamentally creative
death and captivity are right and so i
think there's that element um
and so i think these five years this is
just
i mean it's like five stars in the night
sky right it's not a a container
right they're just kind of points to
look at and so i think part of our job
is not to fit into these but just to you
know make more and more clear the clouds
out the way so we can see all of the
ways our community is getting free
and i think so that's one piece so i
think i think i
am oriented towards a proliferation
approach to abolition
right one in which
i think i said something about this
earlier somebody was saying something
about oh
going towards abolition right and so i
think
certainly in terms of a revolutionary
tradition of abolition or one that's
oriented around um
the end of the prison industrial complex
that's a very clear end goal right and
the press industrial complex is a
like giant black squid of a leviathan
right so to end
so it's one thing to end to close all
the prisons in the world right and so
similar i think it think of it in terms
of practice but you know the oakland
school police department is abolished
right and the day the last cop left
schools are our children safe
no it's a it's one one one particular
kind of vacuum of captivity does not
actually produce the world that we need
and to me that's the distinction between
abolition and liberation right abolition
is i mean and i know ruthie gilmar has
that amazing conception of thinking of
abolitionists growing things again these
are different ways of thinking about it
you know they're all going to work but
for me it's helpful to think about
abolition as that vacuum right and that
doesn't actually take any of the
responsibility away from us to build a
world worth living in
right and that's not it's not only not
an end goal it's also not anywhere near
enough
right and so that's part of what i'm
concerned about too that all of a sudden
the floor has become the ceiling when
the end of captivity has become our our
our dream of what of
that's that's that's what we go to the
altar for that's what we're pouring
libation for just to not be in captivity
and so i don't think so but i think when
part of that cohabitation of language
can also be a domestication of political
imaginaries right and so for me i'm
really invested in abolition because
i like destroying things
so i'm saying that's my gift
i like breaking i like ripping right but
you can't just have that that's just
i
we need a team right and so i think that
so don't mis so i guess for me
nobody mistake my particular interest in
destruction
with a political program because that is
not it you know what i mean it's gonna
be way more so that's that that's one
thing and so then when you said
how do we do this work
dr smith who is me
and i'm asking that because i think that
i was literally thinking about we as in
the small weeds in the room but i really
make that point because that's a good
one because that's part of what happened
in summer 2020.
and it also happens i'll just say you
know as like boujee black people have
moved to another place paying a very
high rent right not always but often the
place that we don't live or living in a
different neighborhood than we grew up
in right
and so i think for me it's important
that who is we is not just about like
race class gender right but also about
like belonging and
different layers of indigeneity and
nativity such that the folks who are
directly impacted are leading the work
of whatever that is so when we're doing
organizing about working conditions in
academia right that that's us right here
right we're doing that right
and when we're doing organizing around
you know the hyper surveillance and
policing of welfare provision right we
are
even if we may have been on wic before
if you're not on wic right now you need
to be in a listening role you need to be
in a like supporting and
and and and amplifying role and so for
me that's why i asked about who is the
because usually i'm not the weak
um and it's my job to really kind of
remind myself that so
yeah that's such an important point
savannah and i think it's also
um
where i
might start to think about kristen's um
question
about uh community and the university i
mean i think that's it's an impossible
relationship
you know especially on a campus like
penn and like many others that has just
continually expanded to the detriment of
the surrounding community and there's
constantly and is
you know this week um
uh organizing around you know building
that's happening um
you know on one particular
end of the campus
so you know we can
understand penn as you know a growing
space that is dispossessing people with
a long history of dispossessing people
and honestly even this building that i'm
in which is the anthropology department
which is in
located in
the penn museum
which was built
on
uh you know the former site of the
philadelphia blockley
uh alms house
across the street is franklin field
which was the potter's field for the
elms house
again dug up and uh you know in order to
create uh the buildings that are
currently here and in fact
for those of you who know some of the
recent history of revelations around
what's going on in the penn museum i
mean some of the
crania who that ended up in morton's
collection come from the bloxley ohms
house and our black philadelphia right
so you know these are the histories we
inhabit that i inhabit daily you know i
walk into this building i am here with
the people living in the building the
ancestors living in the building and on
top of the people whose graves were
destroyed in order to create the
building
so you know
community building
in a universe in this university space
is um you know impossible really like
theoretically impossible
um that said uh again with the view
toward redistributing the resources of
the institution
beyond its uh walls
i mean i think
the arts is really you know a way in
which at least i know how to do that
other people know how to do it through
other mechanisms
but since that is my background that is
the attack that i take and
i mean it's always a negotiation and an
ongoing
um struggle of recognizing uh
recognizing the assumptions that you
have and the moments when you think
everybody's on the same page and then
you realize that you're not and oh maybe
we should have had a conversation about
this or i wouldn't have thought to have
a conversation about this or you know
it's going on right now
um in a good way in a productive and
generative way with the collaboration
that grace sanders johnson and i have um
on a course that we're team teaching
right now called citing black girlhood
and
one of our community partners is the
caller girls museum in germantown that's
run by my very old friend vashtai dubois
and um
you know there have just been moments
when we have to sort of regroup and say
wait what did you mean when you said
that or or how is this how is this going
to work when we travel to jamaica or
when we travel to south africa you know
how are the portraits going to go with
us how are the other portraits going to
join that exhibit you know they're all
of these things that
you know we each may have particular
ideas about the logistics surrounding
them but the logistics come out of a you
know of a theoretical and experiential
um we're asked so you know they're all
things to be constantly negotiated so i
think i would just echo savannah in
talking about
listening and inhabiting the listening
role yes as kristin just wrote in the
chat
um but i would also say that i think
all of these words um abolishing
decolonizing liberating
have um sort of temporalities also i
think there are times
when we do the babarian politics you
know the the hard boring of hard boards
and there are other times when it is the
moment to burn it down you know and we
have to be able to recognize
when
when
when is which time you know when to just
say you know what this isn't going to
work we're not going to be able to go
forward in that way and actually torch
it you know and then sort of move in a
different direction or regroup come up
from the ashes and think again about
what we want to
build you know we can't beat our heads
against the same wall forever we have to
build the new wall and see if it holds
thank you so much for that all of you
i'm looking at the time and i think what
i'd like to do is go to some of the
questions in the chat and i'm going to
combine there's two questions that were
directly
messaged to me and i think they're
related so is it cool with y'all if i
read both of the questions and then we
can see if we can kind of answer them if
you can answer them together and i think
you might have touched on some of
what is being asked in the question so
you could just maybe amplify just a
little bit of what you've already said
but the first one
um
how does care love and tenderness
come into y'all's respective work i'm
thinking about bell hooks
king's beloved community and cornell
west work
amy you started our conversation
expressing the care that you have for
our speakers i'm wondering what
practices you take in your daily lives
that cultivate spaces
or communities of care all right so
that's one question right i think tell
me if i'm stretching here to try to
combine these
how can we keep the sacredness and
rituals by the people we are working
with and learning from
without having to adopt a colonial
supremacist method of the in quotes need
to know or need to explain
can something just be sacred or
unexplainable can part of our method be
embedded in the mystery in our work
and so i throw those two questions out
for you to ask answer them individually
or how you might see them connected
maybe i'll start
um
definitely opacity i think has to be um
a guiding principle of anthropological
work forward and there's there are many
people who have
um
moved toward that in different kinds of
ways and ethnographies that are
models i think of that kind of work i
think on alara's
work
black freedom queer
sovereignty black sovereignty queer
freedom
um uh is one example of of that kind of
work and i think that is care work
you know the respect for
um the right to not be known to not be
parsed to not be described to death
and still in relation
i think that that is definitely part of
a practice of care within a research
process
i think also for uh for me in terms of
practices of care
in life
generally or in the life in the academic
life
you know has to do with gathering and
creating the conditions for gra for
gathering
in ways that can offer
um support and
love and
really a view of the whole person and to
also acknowledge one's own vulnerability
and need for support and love and the
need to be seen
as a whole person and and part of that
is also about mentoring and you know
trying to make sure there are
um more and more and you know
exponentially more black women who are
at the stage where they're able to enact
their true vision you know
um i think black women constitute
christina actually sharp told me this
one time when i was like agonizing over
how many tenure letters i had to write
one year um she told me that two percent
of full professors are black women
and that's why we get asked to write for
every body in every discipline
and i think you know one can see that
and feel that as a burden of course
but if one sees it instead as always
enlarging the community and in always
being in a condition of learning
together and sort of
embracing the work of others
in um
in a fulsome way then i think that too
is part of a practice of care
did um savannah kristen do you want to
address
either the questions or
there's another one oh god we just said
the same thing the same time go ahead oh
no no i mean mine is brief i think i
mean obviously everything that deb said
and
it's interesting that you talked about
the mystery of our work amy because i
think for me
one of the ways of interrupting these
kind of like i'm not sure this is
exactly what you're asking but kind of
these colonial
um affects of extraction
in our in our workspace is that part of
what you're asked is part of what you're
asking about like how do we not
rehearse that when we're in community
um i think
rather than mystery one of the things
that i've really looked to is
transparency result of the inverse so
you might be a string in a mystery when
it shows up on jstor but i think
in the work having more transparency
which i think initially i thought was
about like oh sharing the writing see
what you think about but actually
really being transparent about the labor
like what is the thing that my job is
like how does how does how do you get
paid like what's what is the seed what
do you need to get out of this in order
to keep your job and be very
um clear about kind of the cv and the
you know the
pace of productivity all this other kind
of things that i think are really
submerged in our work and we never talk
about it in the pieces that we're
writing
and we also rarely talked about it with
community right but then as opposed to
being
i think conversations i thought that
initially
um were about like oh you know do you
support this project right so even when
i was doing my dissertation
i
the kinds of relationships that i had
with folks i knew some people already
right i had some relationships i had you
know i've worked at the school for
several years
and when folks participated in the
research it wasn't because they're like
we want to contribute to anthropological
knowledge right it was like oh ms shanke
is going back to school miss shocking
wants to become a professor this is her
dream let's help her everybody right and
people be like this is so good what
you're doing baby we love you we support
how can we help you baby this is so
wonderful and it wasn't because they
were like you're gonna be a great
anthropologist of our community they
were like we see that you want something
and there's something that i can share
with you that helps you get to where you
want to go and that was their gift to me
so it wasn't that i was kind of bringing
back some kind of gift to community it
was really them saying you want to do
this cool thing you want to be a
professor we support you i gotta sign
this thing and tell you a story i got
that right and so that for me was a gift
from community and i think that kind of
transparency moving forward into the
work that i'm doing now to be like hey i
need to write an article in the next two
years it can really be about anything
we can talk ab like the space that we're
sharing right now so the project that
i'm working on right now
um in terms of the political work i was
sharing before talking with folks and
then be like
well i really wanted to work on writing
too that i'm actually a poet is that
something we could do together so now
we're in a very kind of like slow form
process of writing together
what we're thinking of as like a
collective history of the process of
producing the george floyd resolution
right which might at some point show up
in an academic journal or some version
of that but really it was because of
being able to have this conversation
about my labor right and then also being
able to be like this does not have to
enter this space at all
right we don't have to do any of that
and then i will go and write you know
another
another piece about another thing right
and so i think that transparency has
been a part of being able to hold care
um in terms of the kind of
nuts and bolts labor aspect of producing
scholarship
[Music]
i love that so much
and it's it's not savannah there's
nothing i've ever seen in any
sort of um textbook on activist research
methods the transparency question is
never about what you just said which is
really would just change everything in
terms of the relationships that would be
developed right and it's like well i
reveal that how i'm going to use the
research on the irb and signing these
forms of consent but to be really honest
about the capital that is gained for you
as a researcher in the work and what
that means
um thank you for that
i'm wondering if i'm looking i'm gonna
wait for people to add a little bit more
to the chat there's one more question it
that was privately sent to me but i
think it kind of already answered it but
i wanted to see because kristen asks
asked a question
and i'm wondering if deb or savannah you
have a question
for
your
interlocutors here can i say something
about the healing thing really sorry yes
quickly um because i i i mean about the
um
care because i wanted to add this
question of healing
um because at least for me
part of what i've really tried to do in
my work
and when i say work i mean that really
expansively not just in the research
topic but also just kind of like how i
engage with the academy and how i engage
intellectually etc is creating spaces of
healing for people
which is about community building etc
but it's also about caring for the
sacred
right
um and and caring you know caring for
people's
spiritual selves right um and so i
wanted to put that out there because i
think that that's something
that also goes unsaid and people don't
necessarily
talk about that but i mean
um
in a lot of ways what we do
[Music]
can come back to
allowing people giving people the space
and the time to heal
in ways they may not have been otherwise
because of the neoliberal insistence on
production right and so sometimes
we just create enough space
for somebody to just have a moment
where they're actually thinking about
themselves and thinking about their
lives and thinking about what they've
been through um
in a way that's protected and safe
yes yes yes
savannah or deb do you have a question
for
this
collective this trio
if not i can have it i have i have
nothing but i mean i have nothing but
questions but i just like this piece
about
is it great but is it anthropology
um
is wild to hear from you as the person
who literally made me into an
anthropologist like out of thin air
um
because i have
no anthropology degrees
um
and now i had this anthropology position
i think because i was an apprentice to
you in this work i think in a really
real way an old old-time version of how
it means to come into a profession but
just kind of reflecting on this isn't
great but isn't anthropology i was you
know also being asked
um
by people in in great positions of power
in our discipline during job job you
know to get the job that i have right
now what makes you one of us
like really like tests of faith this
kind of test of faith around
anthropology um being
it's just wilder it doesn't stop
to hear that hey i'm not
and i don't mean that i did not say that
is how i got to this
approach tip if anyone here gets that
question answer ethnographically
it works every time
yeah so i'm you know i'm looking at the
time and i'm thinking that we can move
to um closings like what do you want to
leave us with
um
i also had a question about teaching but
i'll save it but just what is
there's so much to think with here i
mean i think we could i mean we could go
on for for two more hours at least but
what is the thing you want to leave us
with or maybe it was that i love that
idea of the burst of light and i think
you put it in the chat savannah that
when we're thinking about those five
nodes or those five tenants really the
stars and the nice guy the burst of
light
and maybe there's something that has
come up in this conversation today that
is another like
star in that constellation that we want
to add to this dark night sky
um
but
yeah can i can i start with you kristen
so to close us out with what you would
want us to
continue to think with
that's a great question i was it's you
said a burst of light and all i could
think about was audrey lord's a burst of
light um and
and really kind of
thinking about you know
what savannah was talking about in terms
of stars and
um constellations which to me bursts of
light and stars all my brain goes
together with those things um
and so i mean for me i think i would
probably leave us with
um
leave us with the thought that in order
for us to be able
to really get to a point
where
our work
is moving us in a direction
that
feels like it ensures
life and it is
freeing right because freedom is a word
we haven't really used yet um but it's
in it's embedded in this question of
abolition and liberation i think that
we have we we have to keep
searching for
new alternatives and
be comfortable with our discomfort
i think that that to me is really
important meaning we cannot get to the
point where we're so comfortable in
where we are that we neglect to remember
the need for constant struggle and for
vigilance and i think to me that is
something um that i want to leave us
with
uh thank you
thank you
okay vigilance oh type goal
savannah did you want to go next
yes because i think debbie had the last
last word
um
because dev deserves the flowers now
not no roses i want ore kids
bougainvillea okay something with a
little flavor a little movement
um but that have i think
this is gonna sound i don't mean this in
itself like a like a what's that word
grandiose way but you know that saying
that folks will ask in certain kinds of
community spaces
um what kind of ancestor do you want to
be
right and thinking about that as an
orientation to
um
political work to life certainly to like
family inheritance right i think it's
also applicable within anthropology
right in terms of what is the table
we're setting for the meal that we're
not ever going to be able to eat right
so like water and deb i really heard you
speaking to this and again like you like
this is this may not be the time of the
space but like the levels to which you
have really created infrastructure for
life and survival
in a place that was not designed for us
and not for yourself right tunnels
pathways bunkers right you are like a
real
general
in this war in ways i don't know has
always said specifically about you so i
just want to lift that up but like
when folks are writing about they think
about like in 2016 somebody's doing a
review of this and that like what is the
thing that they want that you want to be
right before
your little parentheses and not in terms
of your theory right but what is it in
terms of how are you positioning
yourself in this genealogy are you
offering something that might be worth
something to somebody
right
um
and i think that's also true in our in
terms of our teaching in terms of our
family legacies in terms of our
political work because i
you know i don't maybe
listen prove me wrong i don't think that
i'm gonna live to see what i think of as
liberation right
and i also feel like i'm responsible for
offering something that might be of use
to the person who is going to be there
you know at that moment at that day and
it's not going to be something big right
it's going to be something small but i
think that for me is how i orient
towards this and similar you talked
about teaching i really want to talk i
would love to hear your teaching
question but in classes right i hope the
thing that the students get is not the
knowledge is not the content
right not the the the quotation in the
book but something they can take with
them and put in their pocket and follow
between their fingers on a really hard
day you know
yeah that was i'm i'm sorry i was just
tapping in the chat yes yes yes that's
totally how i think about teaching and
then i always feel like i'm doing it
wrong i'm like this is about your your
spirit
right anyway
deb
yeah
i was just gonna say that um and this is
on my mind because um graduate students
and a couple of junior
faculty have raised this question
recently you know they have a thing that
they're passionate about
that they think they should wait to do
until
until what until the dissertation is
done or until i get tenure or until
until until
and
i i think what is important is to
do the thing one is passionate about now
and figure out how to work it into the
thing that's going to finish a
dissertation or get tenure
or whatever because if we do not
live
our
lives our dreams if we do not bring our
whole selves but instead try to contort
constantly into
whatever the figure is that we imagine
people want to see from us
in these spaces then the spaces
themselves will never change
you know and
one does one's own mental health a
disservice to not pursue
[Music]
the important question
the creative writing
the
activism
the organizing all of the above together
whatever it is so i guess what i would
say is
the true transformation can only come
not only because we inhabit these
rarefied spaces but because we inhabit
them as the total people that we are
with the desires that we have and that
we bring everybody with us into those
spaces as well
i think i was writing in the chat so my
teaching question was you all already
answered it i was just wondering how we
you know we've talked about
you know terminology and how we think
about and across institutional spaces
but what does it mean not just in our
own research but in the classroom how do
we teach are we doing that when we teach
um and i don't know who said that about
it's not about the quote you know it's
what can you take with you
to move through these through these
streets ugh anyway
um i just want to say before before we
log off that we have speaking of
teaching and speaking of the next
generation and mentorship that we have
with us in our company
some of the
newly admitted graduate students in
african american studies and so they're
here listening to this conversation
so glad to have you all here so glad you
could make it
um i have nothing but the deepest
adoration for all three of you
and the work that you do is has
liberated
my ability to
be in the academy and i mean that
sincerely um
you know from the first time i met you
deb i realized that it was possible to
be in the academy what is it to be in it
but not of it to be in it but not of it
right and to find that way i think june
jordan talks about this that you're
moving through spaces right like an eel
almost and you without getting anything
on you but as you're moving through
spaces you're creating those tunnels
that savannah was talking about for
others to come through behind you so
maybe they don't have to be so slippery
maybe they can be upright as they move
through those tunnels
ah so anyway
i just want to thank everyone for coming
out i am
please forgive me i do we have another
endeavors session i believe
on the 20 let me look at my
we'll send you all the notification but
we'll be discussing eli anderson's
latest book which will be very exciting
it'll be myself eli
eli anderson and gerald jane so i hope
you all can make that and i'm gonna look
on i believe it's the 20
[Music]
uh
first
but but you'll get a notification about
around that but i just want to thank you
so much kristen
savannah deb
and for all of your wonderful questions
this was this was just like just the
bomb that we all need in these times
and
today i mean that this week like i
needed this so so so desperately um take
good care of yourselves i'll be speaking
to you soon i'm sure thank you all for
coming out
and see you soon and next time